Thanks very much for coming in and
sitting down with me, Parema.
We're building a new app here for
our company.
We're looking specifically at the to-do
and calendar management space.
And so based on the flow that I've
laid out here, I'd like to talk
to you about a couple of different
things that we're seeing with it.
So obviously over here,
we have a very clear screen for
creating and editing new events.
But I'm kind of curious
to understand initially,
coming from the home screen or the data
glance screen, do you see an easy and
clear way to create new entries?
>> Yeah, is that using
the floating action buttons?
>> Perfect.
So the floating action button is
a pattern that we've established across
our application here.
So we have fabs in a couple
of different places.
Fab placement has been a thing
that we've dealt with in the past,
so I'm kind of curious to understand.
On these two screens, we have fabs up
near the hero section of the page.
But over here, we've got our
fab at the bottom of the page.
Does the location of the fab changing,
does that cause any issues for
you or are you comfortable with that?
>> I personally like it with
the hero by the hero banner.
I don't know why, because I'm able
to see all the events down below, so
and then looking over that, and
then I have to go over and search for
the floating action button.
So, which is why I feel,
it's actually kind of nice when
it's with the hero banner.
>> Yeah.
You know even with such a strong
affordance associated with the hero
banner, we can still get at it
here on this screen, as well.
But there is no hero
element to associate with.
And so we still end up
having to roll with it at
the bottom of the screen here.
One of the things too is that,
one of our concerns is that with a fab
of this size, right, that potentially
it could obscure some of the information
that we're looking at here.
Now in this case,
if we're just looking at that,
it's just avatars of the people, but
as you're showing through the list,
there could be more valuable
bits of information.
Do you feel that that would be a real
strong problem for our users, or
they would be able to work
around that with scrolling?
>> I think they would be
able to work around that,
although it does look a little
like blocking some of the content.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> That might happen, but I think once
you get a hang of it and once you're
comfortable with the app, I think
eventually users will get a hang of it.
>> Okay, interesting, so
I have one big question.
Given that this is sort of a to-do
in an event management system,
do you see a clear way to actually say,
I'm done with this particular event?
>> Do you mean to say by just crossing
it off, clearing it from the list?
>> Mm-hm.
>> And just marking.
So I think it's these check buttons.
>> Very cool, okay so you picked
up that affordance quite quickly,
whereas other participants we've
had come through our study
have maybe struggled with
that just a little bit
Why do you feel that that affordance
jumped out for you so quickly?
You picked up on it really.
>> I think it's sort of like
the distinguishing factor between,
one of them was checked, and
the other was not checked.
>> Oh, I see.
>> So, I figured okay, this event
is probably over, or it's done.
So you move on and
check the rest of them.
>> Yeah, it's interesting
though that in this case,
the affordance is just a gray dot.
>> Exactly.
>> So if you were to see three gray
dots here and perhaps not the checkbox,
do you think that that would
stand out as much for you?
>> I think that would be
a little confusing to-
>> Little confusing?
>> Yeah, what does this button do?
Maybe I would be curious to try
it out and see what happens then.
>> Interesting, okay.
So you're willing to be a little
bit forgiving with the application,
try some things to learn
what the pattern is.
>> Yeah.
>> Interesting.
One other big question that's
come up in previous feedback,
is that we can only manage those
events from this particular screen.
Do you feel strongly that we
would want to able to manage them
from something like the home screen?
The home screen is much more of
an at a glance screen, and so
we did not strongly associate
event management there.
Do you still feel that that's valuable,
do we need to go that direction?
>> Yeah, I think it definitely
will be convenient,
since it's listing out the details of
the event, to be able to check it off.
Or are you talking with respect
to details that particularly need
to be in the home screen, or just about
having to manipulate, edit events?
>> It's really solely just about
manipulating or editing the events.
>> Yeah, I think we could add something
like just swiping the event and
giving the user more options
on what they can actually do,
like what editing options they actually
get while doing that function.
>> Interesting.
So if we were to add
some sort of swiper or
some other gesture of support
to one of these screens,
what would your expectation be
that that gesture would do?
If we were to, for instance,
swipe across one of these things?
>> From most of the apps that I've used,
probably have a delete.
As well as maybe a more that
would take you to a list
of functionality, like you know.
>> Would you want to reveal like
a hidden panel behind that thing?
Or go with something that's
a little more like Google's inbox,
where it's just task completion?
>> I think I would want more of a panel.
>> I see, okay.
>> That gives options, more options.
>> You'd would want to see more options?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Interesting.
If we did support something like just
a gesture to mark a task complete,
not a revealed panel.
Would you want that particular
entry to disappear,
would you want it to
remain on the screen?
What would be a clear indication,,
aside from just the blue
checkbox that this event is done?
>> I think that any event that's
done does not need to appear on
the home screen, so
I'm just thinking why it would have
to be on their home screen
once the event is over.
So I would only have checking it off,
would mean it's going to
disappear from the list.
>> Interesting.
Would you have that expectation
of the daily at a glance screen?
Would you want to see things
that have been completed there?
>> Because it sounds to me like in
your heads up in our landing page,
you don't want to see that.
But you do want to see it here?
>> Yeah, in the daily calendar,
daily event list,
I would want to see all the events
that have been completed.
And events that are coming up.
>> Yeah,, I think in previous feedback
we got an indicator that we would want
to see that stuff in
case we made a mistake.
We accidentally swiped something
that we didn't intend to.
Okay, one last question for you, and
then I'll let you get back to your work.
So the one thing that we haven't talked
a whole lot about is how we delete
events, right?
It's one thing to say an event is done,
but I've just made a mistake and
I've created one.
Where would you expect to see
delete come out in this UI?
>> So I think delete would
be when you swipe the event.
Just have a red delete in there.
>> Oh I see.
So you'd want to reveal a panel?
>> Reveal a panel that says delete and
other options, potentially.
>> But if we were to create
an edit UI like this,
where when you tap on one of these
things you come to an edit UI,
you would see the title of the text,
the people.
Would you expect to see a delete
button on that edit screen as well?
I would expect something like
a console to say that oh oops,
I clicked on the new
event button by mistake.
So I don't want to create a new event.
Of course I know that the up
navigation takes you one page back.
But I think a console button to just go
back to the home screen would be useful.
>> Interesting,
you want a stronger affordance there.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Okay, great.
Well I really appreciate all
the feedback that you've given us.
This is really helpful in setting
the direction and the tone for
the next iteration.
>> No problem
>> Thanks for coming out and helping.